we got a lot of requests from Sun
customers to port next step the Sun Sun
says they'd rather stick needles in
their eyes that help us do this how do
you remove the Eagle from the situation
I'm going to give you three suggestions
on execution you don't have to look the
part I mean I certainly never have right
you don't have to sound the part you
just have to find a way to put your
customers in a position to succeed and
good things happen rise and shine it's
an espresso time what's up believe
nation it's evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
be customer driven over to you Steve
Jobs also if you want to hear what Steve
Jobs has to say about confidence check
out my new 250 for confidence series a
lot of people come to me they say well I
want to be an entrepreneur and I go
that's great what's your idea and they
go well I don't have one yet
and I say well I think you should go get
a job as a busboy or something until you
find something you're really passionate
about because it's a lot of work every
day for the next 254 days I will send
you a 30-second two five minute video
for free every morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below
we've also had a lot of requests from
companies to port next step to other
platforms and we're talking to some of
those companies right now now son we got
a lot of requests from son customers to
port next step to sons a lot of them are
saying look we may not want to buy them
anymore but we already bought 500 and we
only throw them in the bay so can we put
your software them because Suns falling
behind in software now son says they'd
rather stick needles in their eyes than
help us do this that's a quote and so
we're evaluating right now which will be
worse for son if we poured it or if we
don't port it and since we're fairly
since we're fairly customer driven we'll
probably end up doing what the customers
asked us to do because we want to make
them happy if you let your ego win you
could lose your business that's what
this clip is all about it's not only
about focusing on the customer it's
about focusing on the mission whether
you have to work with the competition
that you hate or any other sort of issue
it's gonna come up it's your ego that's
getting in the way of you having
ultimate success and so as much as Steve
Jobs hates Sun Microsystems he's willing
to do it he's willing to work with them
if it's better for the customer if it
furthers his mission and I think
entrepreneurs we so often let our ego
get in the way of us doing the thing
that will actually be the best thing for
our business and for our mission I look
at myself as an example I talk about the
little name in my book you're one word
I named him Henry and this is a guy who
was super harsh about my videos told me
that my video sucked this video ended up
becoming one of my best videos of all
time told me I didn't understand how the
internet worked hurl the tonne of
insults at me and it's easy to write him
off it's easy to say this guy's an idiot
he doesn't understand he's not
supporting me he doesn't believe in me
and so I'm never gonna talk to him again
fast forward I don't have any years
later five years later maybe six he
still involved somewhat in my company I
still sometimes reach out to him and get
advice I still consume some of his
content and get ideas for what I can do
with my business because his advice
helps my mission if his advice will help
me become a better mean or be her help
burners grow through the work that I can
create then I'm willing to listen to it
and now I don't even take it on the chin
I'll take the abuse I'll take the
negativity I'll take your flaming if
that's what it takes as long as that is
helping me get to where I need to go if
it's just somebody really an insults at
you and it's not constructive forget it
but I think a lot of times entrepreneurs
live in the world of resentment live in
the world of getting back at somebody
live in a world of this person screwed
me and so I'm gonna spend my time
screwing them over and I think as long
as you're looking in the rearview mirror
you never go forward so many people come
up to me and say hey Evan this guy's
ripping off your channel this guy copied
your clip this guy is doing the same
thing as you but in French or just
switching up the font or the color I
don't spend time thinking about that
because if I spend time thinking about
how one guy is trying to screw me over
then I'm not spending time focused on
the positive and where I'm trying to
grow what I'm trying to build so I think
if you are living in that world of
resentment it's your own ego getting in
your way if somebody is negative and
can't contribute to your mission then
leave them and just focus on the mission
and if somebody's negative and can
contribute to the mission then learn to
be able to take that feedback take out
the the personal ego of it and use it to
help you grow so how do you do it how do
you remove the Eagle from the situation
I'm going to give you three suggestions
on execution number one is always
remember the mission successful
entrepreneur is the best entrepreneurs
are mission driven you're here for
reason you were here for mission you are
here for a purpose you're trying to get
something done I want to solve the
world's biggest problem I want to help a
billion entrepreneurs that's my mission
if you can help me amazing and if that's
being super sweet and sugarcoating
everything and being the nicest person
in the world I love it and if that means
you are the biggest ass in the world but
you can still help me I will still take
that feedback because I'm remembering
the mission because the mission is more
important than me and so if you ever
stuck in these situations where you
think your egos gonna get in the way
remember the mission remember what you
are trying to accomplish tip number two
is replace the protagonist so if you
take out yourself and you take out the
enemy you take out Sun Microsystems if
it wasn't Sun and wasn't you if that
wasn't that history didn't exist what
would the situation look like if there
were two different characters
would your advice be and then follow
your life if it was Steve Jobs
integrating with Sun and he hates Sun
and that becomes a conflict if it was
anybody else if he was looking at his
best friend and some other company that
they had no history together or maybe
they had a great history together
what would the advice be and then go
take the advice take the advice you
would give to somebody else if there
wasn't that personal situation in
between and step number three is swallow
your pride again I think the most
successful entrepreneurs are the ones
who are chasing the big dream and the
dream becomes more important than them I
think too many entrepreneurs are so
concerned about how they look about
being the leader about be able to make
all the decisions about being right
we're so concerned about being right all
the time that we're unwilling to listen
to feedback and we're unwilling to do
some of the things that need to get done
in order to build the business in order
to achieve the mission I am passionate
about helping a billion entrepreneurs I
love you guys I want you to win I think
the best way to do it is for me to be in
front of the camera to make these videos
to deejay concert together if I get a
new idea for something to try that I
think will help the mission I will try
that thing but if somebody came and told
me that cleaning toilets would help me
cleaning toilets with my bare hands
would help me accomplish my mission I
would go and do that because the mission
is more important than me because that's
what I need to go off accomplish it's
not about me looking good and looking
big and being the man it's about the
mission I had a conversation with
somebody close to me who helps a lot of
thought leaders helped experts help
speakers helps authors get known and he
said I have a hard time with you because
a lot of people we deal with they loved
the limelight they loved the attention
they loved being out in front they loved
putting on a show they need that
attention to win where the problem with
me was I didn't I didn't care about that
stuff I don't care about be in front of
the camera I care about accomplishing
the mission and me being in front of the
camera helps that happen and so I will
do it and I will struggle through it and
make thousands of videos and be totally
embarrassed by my own content especially
at the beginning
and so swallowing your pride and
understanding that this thing has to
happen and it's not about you
a son about your role in it it's about
that thing happening and whatever you
need to do to get there within ethical
boundaries you're gonna go and do now
we've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what is one circumstance that
you face recently where you had to
swallow your pride where you have to do
something for the mission that you
didn't feel great about or felt
uncomfortable about or was damaging your
ego but you did it anyway because it
helped the mission grow share your story
in the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso and enjoy
the bonus
[Music]
everybody's got ideas you know that's
that's the easy part
but customer what sale customer customer
happy yes or no sale customer customer
happy yes or no right sale because
everything just feeds that right
everything else is noise and if you and
part of that though so there is a part
beat of that right because one tenets of
good businesses always listen to your
customers right you always want to
listen but you don't always want to do
what they tell you
right because the customers job is to
just is to make their company successful
right and when they tell you what they
need and what they tell you what they
want they're typically thinking about
the right here and now they're not
thinking about your potential
competitors they're not take thinking
about the future of your organization so
you have to also innovate you have to
differentiate so you have to have be
over out here innovating differentiating
understanding you know how you fit
within your industry and how you can get
ahead but then you have to turn that
into sales customers customer happiness
and so if you can execute on those
things things typically work out well
it's not well my office is pretty my
office always looks like crap right I
mean our offices now we we have these
very desks everywhere I'm not it you
know you don't have to look the part I
mean I certainly never have right you
don't have to sound the part you just
have to find a way to put your customers
in a position to succeed and good things
happen well we studied the e-commerce
nobody believed that China would have
ecommerce because people believe on the
one she face-to-face and all kinds of
networking traditional ways there's no
trusted system in China he had to
overcome centuries of tradition by
showing Chinese buyers and sellers that
they could trust
Alibaba with their money in this new
virtual world he did it by guaranteeing
the transactions and creating his own
payment system an escrow account where
Alibaba holds the buyers money until the
goods are delivered every day we finish
more than 13 minute rez actions and that
means that there
you are buying things from somebody you
have never seen you are giving products
to the person you have never met and
there are some guys you never know that
he's gonna take your products to that
place to that person I want to tell the
people that the trust is there because
it's all about it's all about the trust
and this is sort of like this Steve Jobs
question do you think you should focus
on making something that you believe
people want or something that you want I
definitely think it should I would focus
it should be on something that that that
people want you on but but I think the
the nuance on this is you shouldn't
there's always a question whether you're
making the judgment or you're taking
some survey of people to make the
judgment and and so I'm very much in the
Steve Jobs camp of you want to have like
this ESP linked to the population at
large and understand what they want
better than they understand themselves
and I have I take the view that people
don't generally know what they want and
so if you ask them surveys if you do
market studies you will not actually get
get the right answer and so so there is
something about sort of this inspired
you know intuition inspired intuition
about what what the world is a whole
want so now terrific
world domination honey Empire right I'm
grateful I understand why I'm here I
think because I am so open I wanted to
think and see it's a bloody brief life
all of you have the potential for
enormous success if you want to know
what Gary Vee DJ Khalid Oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video